the lord of the rings trilogy is
littered with epic sacrifices
gruesome deaths and both happy and sad
endings
from mighty warriors to slimy bad guys
here are the last words of these fallen
lord of the rings heroes and villains
before we can discuss final words it's
important to know
which final words we're talking about
after all in addition to author j.r.r
tolkien's original books there's the
animated lord of the rings films created
in the late
70s and early 80s and of course peter
jackson's live
action trilogy in this video we'll go
with a combination of the live-action
adaptations
and the original books however some of
the fallen characters still don't have
concrete last
words in either version when this
happens we'll give a brief rundown of
their final moments
after all actions speak louder than
words
while not a primary character in the
lord of the rings isildur shows up early
in the fellowship of the ring film
and is referenced throughout the
narrative the ancient warrior who cut
the one ring from sauron's hand
he sealed door dies when he's ambushed
by orcs while trying to escape across
the great river
in the film his last word comes long
before his death
when he rejects elrond's plea for him to
throw the ring into the fires of mount
doom
destroy it
however in tolkien's book unfinished
tales isildur's final line is a bit
juicier
knowing he's about to be killed
isildur's son alindor
tells his father to bring the one ring
to the elves before it's recaptured
his father replies i knew that i must do
so but i feared the pain
nor could i go without your leave
forgive me and my pride that has brought
you to this doom
easeldore's father ellen deal is the
first king of the realms of gondor and
arnor at the end of the second age
during the same time gilgalad is an
elven leader
who rules over the bulk of the elves
that remain in middle earth
eventually sauron picks a fight with
them and the two leaders form the last
alliance
a massive coalition that gathers
together to attack sauron and mordor
the last alliance is ultimately
victorious but at the expense of both of
these high kings
they are killed in combat with sauron
just before isildur cuts the one ring
from the villain's hand
using his father's broken sword while
neither character is officially given
final words
they appear in both the books and films
their brave actions set the stage for
sauron's first defeat at the end of the
second age
everyone is fascinated by smeagle the
hobbit-like creature
eventually known as gollum he steals the
one ring from a friend on his birthday
and in the process murders his companion
that friend is deigle
another hobbit-like creature five
centuries before the lord of the rings
story begins
diego finds the one ring while out
fishing with his friend
when smeagle sees the ring he demands
that diego give it to him since it's his
birthday
in the opening scene of return of the
king the poor fellow's response winds up
being his last
why in the book diego says a little more
telling smeagol i don't care i have
given you a present already
more than i could afford i've found this
and i'm going to keep it
sadly poor deagle doesn't realize the
tragic irony in his statement
and winds up paying a much greater price
although gandalf doesn't technically die
he certainly gives everyone the
impression that he does
so his seemingly final words are still
worth noting
while staring down the ball rock he
shouts you
shall not pass
unfortunately although gandalf
successfully defeats the balrog
the fiery monster winds up taking the
wizard down with him
as gandalf realizes he's about to fall
he cries out to his friends
fly you fools identical in both book and
movie
the words communicate a sense of care
and frustration
which pushes the rest of the fellowship
members into interaction
while he does return later in the story
gandalf's sacrifice is still a powerful
moment that's earned a spot on this list
also known as durin's bane the fiery
balrog demon
seems indestructibly powerful in the
fellowship of the ring
but the book reveals he's actually a
refugee
fleeing from the catastrophic war of
wrath in that war
sauron's original master morgoth is
defeated
and his surviving servants scatter
across the continent looking for places
to hide
the balrog relocates deep beneath the
dwarf kingdom of kaza doom
for nearly two thousand years eventually
he's disturbed by the dwarves at which
point he drives them away
and the area becomes known as moria or
the black pit
when the balrog attacks the fellowship
gandolf confronts the demon on the
bridge of kazadoon
and sends them both tumbling into the
abyss below
as they fall they begin an intense duel
that progresses from deep
underground all the way up to the top of
the mountains above
there with clouds fire and lightning
surrounding them
the balrog is finally killed by gandalf
the balrog doesn't get any last words
but its death clears the way for the
drawers to eventually return to their
ancient home of kaza doom
while most of the main characters in
peter jackson's film are from tolkien's
original text
the uruk-hai captain lertz was entirely
jackson's creation
lurtz lead saruman's forces in pursuit
of the fellowship
and provides an effective foe for the
main characters to defeat
in the otherwise villainless finale of
the fellowship of the ring
after shooting boromir full of arrows
the orc captain takes on aragorn in a
one-on-one duel
after a harrowing showdown the ranger
wins out
and lertz meets his demise with his arm
and head removed from his body
lurtz doesn't have many lines in the
film and doesn't say anything at all as
he quietly duels multiple members of the
fellowship during the film's ending
battle
however shortly before his last breath
the uruk high
can be heard shouting to his men
created with only one purpose lurk's
final words are focused on his mission
just like his whole life heir to the
steward of gondor
boromir joins the fellowship of the ring
only to succumb to the lore of the ring
but after attempting to steal it from
frodo boromir repents and sacrifices his
life defending mary and pippen
moments before he takes his final breath
boromir confesses
to aragorn that he tried to take the
ring and that mary and pippin have been
kidnapped
he also urges aragorn to go to help his
people before uttering his final words
i would have followed you my brother
my captain
my king the revelation that boromir
finally accepted aragorn as his king
is the perfect way to resolve his
previous scorn for the ranger at the
council of elron
in the books boromir's final line reads
farewell aragorn go to menasterith and
save my people
i have failed aragorn responds that
boromir has not failed but conquered
prompting a smile from boromir before he
breathes his last
in tolkien's books the elf hall deer
helps the fellowship out as they travel
through la florian
but after the travelers depart down the
great river we don't ever meet him again
in the movies though peter jackson
brought back the law florian guide for
the climactic battle of the two towers
as the men of rohan prepare to fend off
saruman's hordes at helm's deep
paul dear unexpectedly shows up with a
bunch of high-quality archers
unfortunately in the ensuing battle
paulder meets an untimely death
just before hall dear's death he shouts
something in his native tongue to his
retreating men
however since we aren't sure of the
translation we'll instead highlight the
last thing he says
after arriving with his troops facing
king theoden
he says he brings word from elrond
saying that they wish to honor the old
alliance between men and elves
we are proud to fight alongside men once
more
originally sent to resist sauron saruman
the white wizard eventually becomes
corrupted and vised for power himself
this leads to his overthrow in the two
towers and his eventual death at the
hands of grima wormtong
in the return of the king in the
extended film version
saruman's death comes as he stands on
top of the tower of orthanc
in the midst of the drowned ring of
eisenguard as he argues with gandolf and
his allies
wormtongue attacks him from behind
sending him careening off the edge of
the tower
just before he's killed saramond can be
heard saying his last words
you withdraw your god and i will tell
you where your doom will be decided
i will not be held prisoner in the books
sorrowman survives until the end of the
return of the king
by then he's going by the name sharkey
whom frodo and his friends discover has
orchestrated the destruction of the
shire
defeated at last by the hobbits sarman
orders a broken worm tongue to follow
him saying
you do what sharky says always don't you
worm well now he says
follow at that the worm tongue of the
books finally turns on his master and
slits his throat
we first meet grima wormtongue secretly
betraying his king theoden
after his duplicity is discovered he
openly allies himself with the powerful
ceremony
fleeing to the white wizard's domain at
isengard
there he serves his new master
faithfully yet miserably
in the films he meets his ending early
in the extended version of the return of
the king
after stabbing saruman in a fit of rage
worm tongue is felled by an arrow fired
by legolas
his last word uttered moments before is
in defiance of saruman's dismal
prediction of his future
free he will never be free now
in the book the return of the king a fed
up grima backstabs sarman again
this time in the shire after his master
is defeated by the hobbits
just before he slits saruman's throat
and is shot by arrows
wyrmtongue is accused by his master of
murdering frodo's cousin to which he
violently hisses
you told me to you made me do it
they didn't is already quite old when
gandalf frees him from the spells of his
counselor grima wormton
after regaining control of himself the
king of rohan leads his armies to helm's
deep
where they win an epic victory by the
skin of their teeth they then head to
menace tirith
where the aged ruler dies in a glorious
charge that kicks
off the battle of the pelinor fields
it's none other than the witch king
himself who kills theoden in battle
in the movies his airborne beast lands
on the king whipping him around and
sending both
theodin and his horse flying to their
deaths in the books
it's clarified that the witch king
actually kills theodon's horse
who then falls on the king crushing him
to death
after eowyn and mary defeat the witch
king together
we get two different sets of theoden's
final words
in the film the return of the king
theoden says to eowyn
i go to my fathers
in whose mighty company
i shall not now feel the shame he then
whispers her name
one last time before he dies in the book
dayden doesn't realize that eowyn is
nearby
his final words are spoken to her
brother ayomir when he says
hail king of the mark right now to
victory
bid aoen farewell both the book and the
film give theoden
satisfying last words worthy of the
noble king he was
the millennia-old witch king is a
recurring villain throughout the lord of
the rings trilogy
he leads the nine ring rafes on their
deadly hunt for the ring
stabs frodo at weathertop and leads the
massive army that attacks menace tariff
after wreaking havoc on middle-earth for
thousands of years the witch king
finally meets his end during the battle
of the pelinor fields
overconfident from millennia of
successes and a prophecy that no living
man can kill him
he recklessly gets involved in the
fighting after mortally wounding king
theoden
he is confronted by eowyn and mary who
worked together to finish him off
in the movie his ironic last words to
aon are
no man can kill me
die now
in the books his final words are a
little different but still set up
eowyn's iconic response before she
strikes the killing blow
i am not mad
[Music]
although he's barely mentioned in the
books gothmag is second in command
during the siege of menace tariff
however in the film version of the
return of the king gothmog gets a much
larger role as a leader high on his own
authority who is convinced that the age
of the orc is about to begin
his involvement in the films makes him a
big enough character to deserve a spot
on this list
in the return of the king we see him
ordering his soldiers around
dodging boulders and commanding his men
to brace for the charge of the rohiro
later in the battle gothmog can be seen
crawling towards the wounded aoe
with his weapon lifted to kill aragorn
and gimli arrive in the nick of time and
finish him off
in order to catch his last words you
need to back up to just before the
riders of rohan come crashing into his
army
prepping his troops for the incoming
tidal wave his last words are the doomed
command
as the steward of gondor dinathor is in
charge of leading gondor in the absence
of the true king
eventually he breaks down under the
pressure of the ongoing attack from
mordor
and tries to burn himself and his son
faramir alive
in the movies as gandalf and pippin
arrive to stop him from murdering his
son
dynador's desperate near final words are
you will not
take my gun from me after gandolf knocks
him back onto the blazing pyre
denithol gazes on his son and quietly
utters his name as his last word
before running from the room and falling
to his death
in the books denethor's last lines are
directed at gandolf before he lights the
pyre
and then to his servant saying but in
this at least thou shalt not defy my
will
to rule my own end come hither come if
you are not all requient
after this he sets the pyre on fire and
purposefully lies down to die
as he lies there he gives one great cry
and then perishes amidst the flames
although he doesn't appear in the
theatrical version of the return of the
king
the mouth of sauron makes a memorable
appearance in the extended edition of
the film
a powerful official in the dark lord's
bureaucracy
he comes out to haggle with the captains
of the west when they arrive at the
gates of mordor
in the books while the character almost
certainly dies when sauron is defeated
he doesn't get any definitive last words
in the film though
he's beheaded by aragorn after foolishly
taunting the long-lost king of gondor
his last words before his
unceremoniously executed are
and who is this he sealed air
it takes more to make a king than a
broken elvish play
gollum's last words come during his
moment of greatest triumph
right before he meets his demise the
single-minded creature
inadvertently saves the day by attacking
frodo baggins and mount doom
when he chooses to claim the ring rather
than destroy it
biting off frodo's ring finger golem
finally reclaims his most prized
possession
but then slips off the edge of the cliff
and falls to a fiery death
in the film the return of the king his
final words are a victorious chant
before frodo tackles him and they both
tumble off the cliff
in the book golem also gleefully repeats
the words precious
over and over but in tolkien's version
he then steps backward
just a tad too far and slips to his
death without any help from frodo
his final word comes out of the depths
as he wails precious
one last time while sauron doesn't
technically die
nor have any recorded last words his
ending is still worth noting as the main
antagonist of the trilogy
whether you're talking about his fiery
eye falling from a crumbling tower in
the films
or the more spiritual implication of his
defeat in the books
his epic fall marks the climax of the
entire trilogy
in the book the return of the king
gandolf explains what will happen to
sauron
after the ring is destroyed saying that
if the ring is destroyed
then sauron will fall and his fall will
be so low
that none can foresee his arising ever
again
he will lose the best part of the
strength that was native to him in his
beginning
and all that was made or begun with that
power will crumble
and he will be maimed forever becoming a
mere spirit of malice that gnaws itself
in the shadows but cannot again grow or
take shape
so while sauron may not be dead or have
formal last words
there's no doubt that his fall marks a
turning point for middle-earth
gryshnock is an orc captain that shows
up for a brief stint in the two towers
when mary and pippen are being dragged
across rohan in the book
he's the chief of the soldiers who serve
the dark lord
he resists the urakai captain uglug who
wants to speed the prisoners to sauron
and
eisenguard rather than the sauron and
mordor
in tolkien's original iteration
greyshnok tries to spirit away the
hobbits from ooglook soldiers
so he can have the one ring for himself
in this process
we hear his last words which are untie
your legs
i'll untie every string in your bodies
do you think i can't search you to the
bones
search you i'll cut you both to
quivering shreds
i don't need the help of your legs to
get you away and have you
all to myself after this he tries to
escape with both hobbits
but he's written down and skewered by a
writer of rohan
bringing his chapter-long road to a
sudden end in peter jackson's adaptation
the villain's fate is even worse he
survives the rohirrim raid
and chases the hobbits into feign-going
forest limping and already bloodied from
wounds he yanks mary out of a tree
and says let's put a maggot hole
in your belly unfortunately for
gryshnock he doesn't realize treebeard
is waking up behind him
and the end promptly stomps him out of
existence
hama is the doorward of eteros charged
regarding theoden's house
however it turns out he isn't great at
his job since he lets gandalf into the
hall with his staff in hand
inadvertently enabling the wizard to
free theoden from worm tongue's
bewitchmen but apart from his slip up
with the white wizard
he's actually a faithful soldier in the
books
hama releases ayomir from prison arrests
worm tongue
and brings the king of the golden hall
his sword from there
hama follows his lord to the battle of
helm's deep where he tragically dies in
the fighting
his last words come in conversation with
a fellow soldier regarding theoden's
deposed advisor
and the temporarily absent gandalf when
the fellow says that gandalf's eccentric
behavior could be explained by
wormtongue
hama's response is true enough but for
myself
i will wait until i see gandalf again in
the movie version
hama doesn't make it as far as the
battle the captain of the king's guard
is killed on the way to helm's deep
his last words come when he's busy
scouting ahead of the rohirum column
what is it
i'm not sure a few seconds later he's
knocked over by a warg riding orc
whose mount eats the loyal warrior face
first
madrill is a character that was purely
invented for the peter jackson film
adaptations
in the two towers the gondorian officer
witnesses
the events in ethilion where pharamir's
forces ambush the haradri
and then take frodo sam and eventually
gullum prisoner
after that madrill heads back with the
troop of rangers when they return to
osgiliath
in the return of the king he can be seen
helping faramir prepare the hopeless
defense of the same ruined city
when the invading forces led by the
disfigured gothmock swarm across the
river
they overrun the garrison with little
effort amongst the gondorian casualties
is madril
whose last on-screen words are as a
faithful second-in-command
after saving his captain from his orc
pursuers he advises his lord
we can't hold them the city is lost
not long afterward madrill is knocked
down by his enemies and receives a
cold-blooded spear to the heart from
gothmock
as he lays helplessly in his enemy's
path
while not technically dead frodo baggins
absolutely deserves to be on a list of
last words from the heroes of middle
earth
at the end of the return of the king the
ring bearer sails away into blissful
retirement
in the undying land but the truth is
that he does so because he's so
spiritually devastated by the ordeal of
carrying the ring
that he basically can't endure life in
middle earth anymore
as frodo prepares to leave he tells sam
that although he was successful in
saving the shire
the peaceful life that he once lived is
no longer available to
him then as he gives sam the book he's
written about their adventures
he adds last pages are for you
sam in the book after explaining why
he's realized he cannot remain in the
shire
frodo tells his ever loyal gardener and
best friend
that he is his heir and must stay behind
with his family
frodo then finishes with an invitation
for sam to come and see him off at the
harbor
saying come now ride with me
the lord of the rings may not be bilbo
baggin's story
but the entire adventure wouldn't have
taken place
if it weren't for his epic adventure
half a century beforehand
by the end of the lord of the rings
bilbo is a very old hobbit who is waning
quickly without the power of the one
ring to keep him from aging
the hobbit hero leaves his comfy
retirement pad in rivendell
at the end of the return of the king
he's feeling very old at this point
but he rallies his strength to head
overseas to the immortal blessed realm
an honor he's earned due to his legacy
as one of the ring bearers
in the return of the king book bilbo's
last line comes when he meets frodo and
sam on their way to the grey havens
upon seeing them bilbo proudly declares
to frodo
that thanks to the help of the one ring
he has finally become the oldest hobbit
of all time
surpassing even the lifespan of the old
toque his last line immediately follows
this statement as he tells his cousin
and now i think i am quite ready to go
on another journey
are you coming in the movie adaptation
the line doesn't come until they
actually reach the harbor
at which point the elderly bilbo
proclaims
i think i'm quite ready for another
adventure
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more loop of videos about
middle earth are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one